and finally new rule if the Olsen twins
can charge $55,000 for this handbag they
can't make their interns work for free
that's right the Olsons whose company is
worth a billion dollars
sell this bag made from the hides of
other less successful child stars for
fifty five grand
while they're being sued by 40 unpaid
interns who are just trying to get
minimum wage well they'd also like their
brother Hansel to be released from the
fattening cage in the house made of
candy because they look like witches
anyway so I'm sorry Olson's but if you
sell obscenely overpriced crap to status
obsessed suckers and stiff the children
who help you
you're not America's little sweethearts
anymore you're Apple
now I don't want to pick on the Olsens
but if these two aren't guilty of
something why do they always look like
raccoons when you turn on the porch
light of course the Olsons are really
just a reflection of our post greed is
good world where outrageous income
inequality is simply accepted even by
most of the people getting [ __ ] by it
people who should be in the streets or
in unions or at least in the voting
booth but are not as usual Americans
just find it easier to adapt and that's
how we got what economists now call the
sharing economy we used to have stores
that provided jobs then commerce went
online now we just have apps I know
we're supposed to think that's cool to
drive an uber from your Airbnb to the
assignment you found on task rabbit
selling your ovaries but isn't the
sharing economy really the desperate
economy Airbnb you really think anybody
really wants to have total strangers
living in their apartment for a week oh
look someone else's pubes on myself I'm
living the dream
there are apps now that connect you with
people who will buy your groceries or
park your car and on Etsy you can sell
your handmade crafts without the
middleman of the store how liberating
your basically this guy in Venice Beach
now oh and by the way I'm not planning
on wearing these pants tomorrow so if
anyone needs pants but can't afford the
long term investment head over to
trouser deal calm trouser deal where you
can rent my pants for just 595 a day so
how did America spend 60 years fighting
communism and end up in a barter economy
on Craigslist it's like being afraid of
gluten and ending up eating cats and
dogs the Trump's of the world would like
to blame it all on Mexico and China but
actually these soulless workers coming
to take your job aren't being smuggled
across the Rio Grande they're being
built in Palo Alto and that's not
counting the next big thing driverless
cars oh I know we already have that it's
called texting behind the wheel
no I mean real driverless cars but
robots and cars didn't do this we did it
to ourselves as usual by worshipping
greed from replacing people with robots
to exploiting interns from the slave
labor we use overseas to the music
everybody steals at home we've all
become so good at scheming cheating
inventing raiding gouging and just plain
[ __ ] each other that we woke up one
day with the sharing economy with the
one thing we're not sharing of the
profits somehow they forgot to create an
app for that
Hilary Clinton has a detailed plan for
higher education but what is the point
if there are no jobs when you get out
what's the point of going to school
joining the frat and learning the race
its songs if that's weight of all that's
waiting for you is your parents basement
even even jeb bush says we're moving to
a world where it's harder for people in
poverty to move up and his solution
don't raise the minimum wage remember
when we say he's smart we mean smart for
a bush
you